hello i will now introduce you to the
concept of similar triangles
let me write that down similar
similar
similar triangles
so in everyday life what a similar mean
well
triangles no triangles angles
triangles yeah
anyway so it's what a similar mean in
everyday life it means
two well if two things are similar
they're they're kind of the same but
they're not the same thing or they're
not identical right and that's the same
thing for triangles
so similar triangles are two triangles
that have
that have all the same angles
all
the same
angles
for example
let me draw two similar triangles
so i'll draw i'll try to make them look
kind of the same because they're
supposed to look kind of the same but
just maybe be different sizes
so that's one
and then i'll draw another one that's
right here
i'm going to draw a little smaller to
show you that they're not necessarily
the same size they just
are the same shape essentially
one way i like to think about similar
triangles are they're just triangles
that could be kind of scaled up or down
in size or flipped around or rotated but
they all have the same angle so they're
essentially the same shape for example
in this these two triangles if i were to
tell you that this angle this is how
they do it in class this angle
oops i'm still using the line tool if i
tell you this angle is equal to this
angle
and i told you that this angle up here
is equal to this angle
well a couple of things you already know
that this angle is going to be equal to
this angle and why is that
well because
if two angles are the same then the
third has to be the same right because
all three angles add up to 180. for
example if this is x
if this is x this is y
this one has to be 180
minus x minus y right that's probably
too small for you to see but that's the
same thing here if this is x and this is
y then this angle right here is going to
be 180
minus x minus y right so if we know that
two angles are the same in two triangles
and we know that the third one is also
going to be the same
so we could also say this
this
angle is identical this angle and if all
the tri if all the angles are the same
then we know that we we are dealing with
similar triangles
and so what what what useful things can
we now do once we know that a triangle
is similar well we can use that
information to to kind of figure out
some of the sides so
even though they don't have the same
sides the ratio
of corresponding side lengths is the
same i know i've just confused you let
me
give you an example
for example let's say that this this
side is let's say i'm going to draw it
in the
correspond let's see this side is 5.
let's say that
this side is i don't know i'm just going
to make up some number six
and let's say that this side is
seven
right
and let's say we know that
i don't know let's say we know that this
side is
this side here is 2
right
so we know the ratio of corresponding
sides is the same so
if we look at these two triangles
they're they're completely different
sizes but they they have corresponding
sides for example
this side
corresponds to this side
how do we know that well in this case
they just happen to have the same
orientation but we know that because
the sides are opposite the same angle
right this
is opposite angle y and then this side
is opposite angle y again this whole
triangle might be too small for you to
see but hopefully you're getting what
i'm saying right so these are
corresponding sides
similarly
this side
this blue side
and this blue side are corresponding
sides why not because they're kind of on
the top left because we could have
rotated this and flipped it and whatever
else is because it's opposite the same
angle
it's opposite the same angle that's
that's why i always think about
triangles it's a good way to think about
especially when you start doing
trigonometry
so what what is that what does that help
us well the ratio between corresponding
sides is always the same so let's say we
wanted to figure out the s how long this
this side of the small triangle is
well there's a bunch of ways we could do
it we could say that the ratio of
this
of this side to this side so x
to 7
is going to be
equal to
the ratio of this side to this side is
equal to the ratio
of two to five
and then we can solve it and the only
reason why we can do this you can't do
this with just random triangles you can
only do this with similar triangles
so we could then solve for x multiply
both sides by seven and you get
x
is equal to
14 over 5. so it's a little bit less
than three so 14 over five
so 2.8 or something like that that
equals x and we can do the same thing to
figure out this yellow side
so if you know two triangles are similar
you know all the sides of one of the
triangles you know one of the sides of
the other triangle you can figure out
all the sides i think i just confused
you with that comment but let's let's
keep nice so this is this side so let's
call this y
so we could say do it the same way we
could say
y
over 6
is equal to
2 over 5 right it's make sure if you're
doing you know one triangle is going to
be the denominator here then
that same triangle has to be denominator
if one triangle is the numerator
on the left hand side of the equal sign
right so the smaller one's the numerator
then it's also going to be the numerator
on the right hand side of the equal sign
right and i just want to make sure
you're consistent that way if you flip
it then you're going to mess everything
up and we could just solve for so y is
equal to 12 over 5.
so y is equal to 12 over 5.
so let's let's use this information
about similar triangles just to do some
do some problems
image
image clear
image invert colors okay
so let's say i had
let's let's use some of the geometry
we've already learned i have two
parallel lines
and then i have let's see i have a line
like that
then i have a line like this
and what did i say i said that the lines
are parallel
so this line
is parallel to this line
and i want to know
i want to know if
this side is length five
if this length this side is length five
what is
oh well let's say this length is length
five let's say that this length is
let me draw another color
this length is
oh i don't know
eight
i want to know
i need to know what
i want to know what this side is i want
actually no let me let me give you one
more side just to
make sure you know all of one triangle
say that this side is six
right
and what i want to do is i want to
figure out what this side is right here
what this side is this purple side
so how do we do this
so before we start using any of that
ratio stuff we have to prove to
ourselves and
prove in general that these are our
similar triangles and so how can we do
that let's see if we can figure out
which angles are equal to other angles
so we have this angle
here is that
is this angle equal to any of these
three angles in this triangle
well yeah sure it's it's opposite this
angle right here so this is going to be
equal to this angle right here
right and so we know that it's opposite
side is its corresponding side so we
know that it corresponds to
we don't know it's the length but we
know it corresponds to this
to this eight length right
all right let's say i forgot you to give
you some information i forgot to tell
you that this side is let me give it a
neutral color let's say that this side
is 4
right
let's go back to the problem so we just
figure out these two angles are the same
and that this is that angle's
corresponding side can we figure out any
other angles are the same
let's see let's say we know what let's
say we know what this angle is
let's say we know this angle i'm going
to do like kind of a double angle
measure here
so what angle in this triangle does any
angle here equal that angle
sure we could we know that these are
parallel lines so we can use
alternate interior angles to figure out
which of these angles equals that one
but i just saw the time and i realized
i'm running out of time so i will
continue this in the next video